tu es de ce samedi à un mariage était
possible et c'est bel et bien c'est
chose faite nicolas sarkozy a épousé ce
matin carla bruni au palais de l'elysée
c'est le maire du viiie arrondissement
de la capitale qui a célébré cette union
tenue secrète et qui s'est déroulée dans
la plus stricte intimité alexandre kara
olivier pronthus cette fois la rumeur ne
s'est pas trompé 55 faubourg
saint-honoré appareils photos et caméras
sont venus en nombre pour tenter
d'immortaliser les mariés d'élise et
ballets de voitures bouquet de fleurs et
même des journalistes venus de loin une
information au conditionnel qui se fait
officielle en fin de journée
madame carla bruni tedeschi et monsieur
nicolas sarkozy annonce qu'il se sont
mariés dans la plus stricte intimité
il a tellement les médias sur le dos les
photographes les paparazzi il a décidé
de se marier dans l'intimité
il en a discuté avant mon show c'est
carla elle elle aurait préféré un
mariage à la mairie
pas de mairie mais un maire à domicile
le premier magistrat du viiie
arrondissement de paris est venu par
dérogation célébrer le mariage à
l'elysée ambiance certaine émotion
un peu ému
deschamps d'alliance et les mariés
d'être habillées en mariée si je puis
dire en mariage civil
la mariée était en blanc comme il se
doit une grande robe non on en a les
piétons robe normal la hanche et le
présent de la république en costume
cravate sombre ensemble la première fois
en public c'était à disneyland il ya six
semaines
depuis il y a eu les gip le nil les
pyramides et cette petite phrase lors de
la conférence de presse de janvier
becquart ladd ont décidé d'assumer
et puis vous l'avez compris c'est du
sérieux divorce puis re mariage c'est
une première pour un président de la
république en exercice
carla bruni troisième épouse du
président est ainsi désormais la
première dame de france
pour l'heure l'agenda l'elysée n'a prévu
aucune date pour la lune de miel
la france a donc depuis ce matin une
nouvelle première dame carla bruni et
italiennes